اذا اللغه الصينيه يعود تاريخها لاكثر من
3000 سنه وتكتب من اليسار الى اليمين او
من اعلى الى اسفل هناك واحد من كل سته
اشخاص يتحدثوا اللغه الصينيه واكثر من
مليار شخص يتحدثون بها كلغتهم الام ما
يفوق عدد المتحدثين باللغه الفرنسيه
والالمانيه والاسبانيه والانجليزيه
مجتمعين لغه لا تعتمد على الابجديه هذا ما
يجعل نظام الكتاب فيها صعب جدا بالاضافه
لاحتوائها على الاف الحروف المستقله كما
ان اللغه الصينيه تحتفظ بنفس شكل الاسماء
ايا كانت هي مفرد او جمع ايضا لا تحتوي
على ازمنه للافعال الخاصه بها فبدلا من
استخدام لعب ويلعب يتم استخدام قبل وبعد
للتعبير عن الزمن كما ان نغمه الصوت في
اللغه الصينيه تغير المعنى تمام ا لذا هذا
ما يفسر نطق الصينيين لبعض الكلمات بصوت
اعلى وتعد اللغه الصينيه لغه رسميه من
اللغات الست في الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات